love this guy um i i miss broadcasting
with him
and i'm not just saying that because
he's on hold getting set to join us he
is the general manager of the las vegas
raiders mike mayak have you been mike
hey rich i'm pretty good how'd the uh
the show go last night i
it kind of always amazed me that you
could do a show
wrapped around a schedule release
celebrating paperwork mike that's
essentially what we're doing
you know that's his three hour show
celebrating the arrival of paperwork is
literally what last
last night was but you know we've been
making chicken salad since the very
beginning and you were part of all those
years
you know somebody sent me a picture of
the first combine we did years ago and
it was just
it kind of took you back to the old
stadium in indy
and you know nope just bare bones
everything i i forget how many people
were
at the first senior bowler the first
combine rich but
there weren't many of us right well you
i think it was you and bert
paul burmeister one of the great humans
on the planet in in like
folding chairs on the sidelines of the
rca dome i wasn't even there
the first time we started turning the
cameras on because you know the
competition committee was like you want
to televise what
like are you kidding me you're like that
wasn't that was kind of a non-starter
and you
the way you handled your business and
paul handled his business and i think we
had jim moore senior on there too
kind of helped tell bill paulian that
you know we're not going to be in your
face we're just going to respect
respectfully cover this whole thing for
sure
you know what was funny was that we were
in the folding chairs
right down by the players while they
were working out the first day was the
offensive line and
literally it was almost like being in a
hockey rink where the players saw you on
the other side of the glass
and they could hear us and the offensive
line was working out i made a comment
about one of the players
and i said you know i think he'll
probably be a third or fourth round guy
he's not real quick
and you could hear him cursing me out
like you can't believe
clearly on the air he heard everything i
said and was mf and me like crazy
meister of course couldn't stop laughing
i bet you know it's it's funny mike with
the pandemic i'm reading articles about
how
um athletes are hearing announcers what
they're saying to them because there's
no fans in the stands
and and how that's been so you you had
that sensation
you know when it was at the combine you
know and and
and you know while we're on the subject
of fans in the stands
um boy oh boy the first time that uh
fans are gonna be in the stands for las
vegas raiders game in that beautiful
stadium
um can't be any bigger a monday night
game against the ravens
uh is that what left out to you when you
first got the schedule yesterday walk me
through your
process of grabbing a schedule as the gm
of the las vegas raiders
like mayakis yeah i mean i think the
first game is an important one obviously
and um out of all the franchises in the
league
uh the ravens are one of the ones one of
the three four five franchises that i
respect
the most i i think there's been um
a degree of excellence set for years and
it didn't matter was brian billick or
john harbaugh
ozzie newsome was kind of the glue
behind it now eric
acosta they've got an amazing
quarterback and they're one of the most
physical teams in football so
you know monday night last year rich we
went
six and two on the road and two and six
at home
and we need to get that place
just rocking and rolling with with
raider fans
and we need to set new deckable records
and we need to kind of set a tone
for the new allegiance stadium and then
the like the ravens at pittsburgh
and that's another thing i might imagine
you you look at are those
one eastern road trips right you got one
for the giants as well in november i'm
looking here you got a one
you know i got a noon uh kick at kansas
city
at indianapolis one eastern uh that that
is uh
you know obviously got a plan when you
play them but that's not terribly
optimum
for you on the road no and you know week
two was tough because
the league was good enough to send us to
pittsburgh on a short week
across the country
yeah i'm picking that philly uh
conversation up for me right there i'm
picking that up
so uh yeah yeah so we got a challenging
start and that's what kind of
that's what you asked me what hit me
first sure you know what we're going to
embrace it i mean that's two of the
better franchises in the nfl back to
back one on a short week that's fine
let's go
mike mayonna that's the way we have to
look at it mike mack here on the rich
eisen show
walk me into uh the moments of uh when
you're on the clock you and gruden and
what you guys
do together how you work together that
is a a
fascinating subject for a lot of
observers i'm i'm sure you're
you might shrug your shoulders as to the
question as to why but you know as you
know you're
the head coach that uh you are uh
evaluating with is a fascinating figure
in this league
walk me what is that like when you're on
the clock and the raiders and you and
gruden are in the draft room together
mike but well i most of the work ought
to be done before the draft starts
and you ought to have a plan and
obviously
the plan changes at different times and
and for us what was kind of cool
you know we knew we were going to go get
leather wood in the first and whether or
not we traded down was going to be up in
the air
i was hoping to trade down and it didn't
work out
however the next day
you know we've got with again you go
home that night
and we're sitting at 48. you know
and we're thinking about there's three
pretty good safeties out there and the
number one on our list
was uh trayvon uh merrick and
i thought he was going to be one of the
first two or three picks on the second
day because we thought he was going to
be going on the first day
and he starts sliding a little bit and
john and i are kind of looking
at the board and going okay dallas is at
44.
he probably won't get past dallas um
so we i picked the phone up and started
calling and
had had a conversation with san
francisco earlier that day
who was at 43 you know before the draft
started
uh we talked a little bit about a flip
right there they wanted to potentially
move down we might want to come up
so that was kind of discussed in advance
i got adam peters on the phone
um who's an outstanding scout and john
lynch's assistant
uh and adam i kind of worked it back and
forth and sure enough
merrick made it to 43 and john and i
couldn't have been happier so
we traded up in two and we traded back
up in four
because another safety who we had a big
grade on slid down on the bottom of four
and that's uh tyree gillespie from
mizzou so the
i think the fun part rich was you kind
of know what you want to do
and what how you're trying to attack it
but when things come up that you don't
expect
how do you react well john was awesome i
was just like john we got to go get this
guy
and he was all in and the same thing in
the fourth round he was all in
so um that's what to me that's the most
fun part of the draft is when
you get thrown kind of a curveball and
how do you react to it mike mayok
general manager of the las vegas raiders
here on the rich eisen show so
going into um the non-playing season
is you know we call it on nfl network
and then the talent
evaluation portion and free agency have
you attacked
the defense in the manner that you're
you you wanted
where where do you where do you feel
about your defense which you
came on the draft uh show with uh
me and the guys uh and i'm sure you have
mentioned this many times that that was
something you needed to
attack from the coaching staff all the
way through to what you could control
so what do you think now that we're in
mid-may
well i mean time will tell but um
we knew we needed some edge speed we
needed
some twitch on the outside in gawkway
became a really important piece to that
uh and then in the draft we feel like
malcolm koontz is a guy that could
develop in a similar fashion
so we've got what we hope
is some twitch coming off the edge to
kind of provide a balance between max
crosby and cleve sorrow on the other
side
we also think clea did a real nice job
kicking inside last year
prior to getting hurt and then we had to
attack the inside position and you know
we signed solomon thomas clinton
jefferson
darius pylon um
we kind of we're hoping rich that our
defensive line
uh is a lot more disruptive than it was
a year ago and
and that that's point number one we've
got to be way better up front
uh we think we we can run at the second
level now with the linebacker position
uh both what we did last year and what
we did this year
and to be honest we got to play better
on the back end
and you know we've invested draft
capital back there
we've invested more now with the second
round safety
so you know we're hoping that john abram
and trayvon
mary become the type of pair that gus
bradley envisions
with a high safety you know high post
safety and a strong safety
and then our outside guys got to play
better and and they know that you know
damon arnett
trayvon mullen uh we we signed a veteran
casey hayward that'll be a true pro
so that's kind of a long way of saying
rich that you don't have
any clue what's going to happen until
the season gets here but
we were a pretty good offensive team
last year and a really bad defensive
team
and that's got to change well and on in
terms of the offense um
you know you you came on again uh always
kind of come
back home if you will to us on nfl
network uh
you and uh and i spoke with dj daniel
jeremiah in the booth at the last
in-person combine and i'm sure you
remember it because
that was when tom brady was about to hit
the free agent market and i attempted uh
to make you uh take the cheese on that
conversation and you you saw that coming
a mile away and did not
um and that chuckle means that you do
remember that
um and so your your current
quarterback is still your current
quarterback and everybody thought that
when gruden was coming he might not like
your current quarterback and he's still
your current quarterback
so what what is the what is what does
the offense look like with derek carr
this year and moving forward what what
what is uh carr's role in everything
according to your viewpoint
mike i i think john and i are both
excited and energized by derek carr and
what he's done the last couple years
with john
i thought he's made a a step forward
each year
i thought he was one of the better
quarterbacks in the nfl last year
and if he takes another step forward
he'll be a very very special quarterback
he derek can play
and last year dirk was not one of our
problems
and what we did this year rich which
kind of has the whole building energized
right now is
we're revamping our offensive line so
you know i think it's more about how
quickly that unit develops
we feel like we've got some real talent
at the skill positions
we feel like we've got one of the top
quarterbacks in football
and our offensive line is in there
working their tails off every day
we feel like we got younger and more
athletic but we certainly gave up a
savvy veteran presence in
in both our center rodney hudson and our
right guard gabe jackson you know
why did you do that before you've got to
develop why did you do that mike that's
a lot of people are wondering why did
you do that i mean you had veteran staff
veteran savvy i mean you just used two
two uh adjectives you you'd normally
want to
ascribe to your line why did why did you
do that with the line
i i have all the respect in the world
for those two guys um
both of them were in there were getting
into their 30s now
um they both made plus or minus 10
million dollars a year you know trent
brown was in the 14 million dollar area
um so between the three of them there
was about 34 million dollars of salary
we offloaded
and while we did that we think we got
younger and more athletic and that's
with all due respect to rodney and gabe
uh but you know we draft a first round
right tackle
uh we think john simpson our left guard
from last year who took in the fourth
round has a chance to be really good
you know we still have denzel good we
still have richie incognito
um we resigned our left tackle
colt mill to a big contract and we think
andre james
has a chance to be a really good center
so you know
there comes a time you know we we got
andre as a
undrafted free agent three years ago we
think he's going to be very good
and so he's less expensive he's younger
he's more athletic
and we're excited about the changes to
our offensive line
mike i appreciate the the chat and uh as
a thank you
um i'm gonna do what i always love to do
with guests and certainly since you are
uh special um in the regard that i've
known you for a long time i'm going to
do my best to leave you in a better
place
and in that regard mike um is you
mentioned earlier that having fans in
the stands
in vegas is going to be great and you
can't wait and they have to be loud
they have to be rocking we have all seen
the news this week about the the club
the vegas type club that's going to be
there
uh in the end zone with what i assume is
mike mayok generally managed bottle
service
um and put it all together mike
um we have the dj for you we just need
your help to get mike del tuffo the gig
your thoughts i don't even know what
you're talking about
that was my windup i took a long wind up
admittedly and i appreciate your
evaluation of that because you always
evaluate i understand
but you don't know about this nightclub
that's in the end zone uh
that was announced this week that's
coming it's a it's a new club win
resorts is
is is conceiving it tvs premium dj's
bottle service on the field level suites
no you don't know that
when it comes to the end zone rich i
always i only care about which jerseys
get there well done look at me care less
about the rest of it well no hold on a
second no but this could get
folks riled up you know and if
del tufo you know michael not paying
attention people drinking drinks and not
paying attention to the game
well maybe you need them to get you know
be full
maybe you get a you get a false start by
the the you know your opponent out of
this thing you know what i'm saying i
mean so
delta you focus for whatever we need to
do to get that place loud well
i haven't even know what you're talking
about but let's get loud
mike can spin the records you know mike
so
you know let's i'm just trying to help
you out here
get him in touch with the right guys
i've never been more appreciative of
your help
thank you mike dell twofold i'm trying
there's only so much i can do it's just
every so
often every now and then i always feel
like i'm holding i'm taking on water
with mayok it's been a while since i
felt that way but uh now here i am again
mike you take care of best two best to
your family best to lee
uh we all miss uh seeing her uh around
certainly nfl network
so you take care you'd be well thankful
it's best for you guys and your family
yeah right that's
you guys that's mike mike everybody the
best answer we could have gotten from
mike mack
i don't know what you're talking about
that was amazing
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here